e se derrubarem nós nós levantar de novo
porque hoje nós é um milhão de bichos
soltos a meninada está muito quieto não
é só muito medieval e aí a gente o
planalto com vocês se não tiver vai
ficar bom agora qualquer vídeo novo
vídeo onde hoje está muito bom que eu
sou muito bom não combinar com muita
sensualidade e como é o vídeo eu pedi
uma pessoa que me pec é como é e eu
pedindo às pessoas que me seguem e o
twitter para me mandarem perguntas por
responder para vocês e soube que as
fêmeas perguntas sobre sexo e
relacionamento aí já vai falar sobre
sexo isso tem muitas crianças que
assistem o inverso tem muitos
adolescentes que assistem mas o isso
como será falado acontecem muitos pais
que assistem também olha olha se você é
um pai de alguém que me assiste você é
uma pessoa que assistia menor de idade
se tem que entender uma coisa o mundo
todo tá uma merda o mundo inteiro é uma
merda as pessoas que têm um delas são o
extrato da merda você não tem que privar
seus filhos assistir às foi privações
que eles sabem das coisas você tem que
ensinar o seu filho a caminhar no meio
da mental health tech similar com o
menos possível na merda do mundo se eu
tô falando essas coisas pra você pode
ter certeza que é pra ajudar o seu filho
no futuro a seu governo não pergunto meu
pai pelo meio do meu pai fica com a
catana e matar a não vou perguntar pra
minha mãe se perguntar pela mãe pode ser
que eu amo rei a minha mãe gosta de
conversar sobre isso não falo isso como
então vai saber aqui
a criança aprende ela perdeu o jeito que
sabe se está ligado que o filho de vocês
quando você sai de casa não fica lento
tabuada não lhe faz o outro
vamos às perguntas além do tac o twitter
que me segue no twitter no twitter sic
vai vai aparecer
basicamente o que segue no twitter pra
você nunca perder tudo bem se perguntar
vocês sabem então vamos aqui ó pergunta
tá bom tá aqui no computador me
maravilhoso e vamos lá pergunta lucas
mais perto já chupam cuidar e o que você
acha sobre fazer isso bom você que é um
pai de alguém de dentro da cela onde
estava na 1ª vara falou de curso ou eu
sou filho de vocês e perguntas foi o de
1998 o que o relacionamento tem que ter
para superar a distância capaz no mínimo
dinheiro para comprar passagens não como
é que é e contra ele
a tatiana perguntou ilhas o que você
acha namoro à distância a eu acho o bem
distante né topo longe a gente namorou
distância não é problema nem porque como
diz aquele provérbio chinês mas vale um
a bola na mão do que dois voando deus
ajuda quem cedo madruga está com
passagem de pessoas e tem que ser uma
pessoa apresentar também não dá pra
namorada de quatro anos sem ver pessoa
não tem como mas sei lá de vez enquanto
atleta disse o estudo define a primeira
vez de uma mulher na visão do homem a
primeira vez de uma mulher na visão do
boto vaga
roberto eu para a bota de pagar
ai ai ai ai roberto o bota cup vai de
novo bota de novo vai tá muito tá queira
bota e tira volta e isso ai ai roberto
pacheco já foi todo meu deus vou repetir
aqui o menino que cabo de vassoura viu
tinha no meu peito por favor eu tava me
tratado no meu peito de cada um pode
botar aí roberto de vaga que dá com a
doença
o jota ponto ribamar pinto ruins você
acredita que a relação sexual só devia
ser feito depois do casamento
eu acreditava que sim até o fazer mas
isso não quer dizer que você então fazer
também isso vai muito de que cada pessoa
tem pessoas que para ela é melhor depois
do casamento e tem pessoas que para ela
é melhor é mais propício ser feito antes
do casamento devem muito a criação da
pessoa louca entanto ruiz você já vestiu
fantasia na hora do sexo não é negócio
norte o ganso vai retirar é o slu que
perguntou inglês só a partir de quantos
meses você acha que é bom ter a primeira
relação com sua parceira motos ao
pessoal de ordens ou ceará
a rádio horizonte a um cheiro para você
do que você tem que entender uma coisa
relação sexual não tem dia para fazer
não tem hora para fazer relação sexual
só depende uma coisa preparo quando os
dois estão preparados para fazer pode
fazer pode ser um indício de amor fé e
no amor um mês dois anos prepara o homem
quase sempre está preparado e só toma
desta vem aqui conversar ou do carimbó
também mas pra mulher não é a mulher até
a casa em segurança no nosso meio
nervoso etapa quando estiver preparada
já pode já não tiver espere espera a
roupa ao ex bairos perguntou isso
perdoaria uma traição não
então é isso galera vai te ajudar por
fernando só a vida sexual sexual se você
gostou é muito importante você deixa um
líquido vier ao rio além de postar no
facebook ou no facebook há muito bom a
então se clique em curtir semarh com
amigos e nos comentários
aí a no twitter e dar rt drt mas a gente
viu é assim que manda
também quero agradecer muito vocês que
nosso canal chegou a um milhão e
trezentos mil inscritos sabe que é isso
aí é a sustentação da taco a taco a taco
gato
muito obrigada a assistir vir até aqui
valero é nóis